today's topic this comes from another
youtuber who's dealing with a situation
someone sent it to me so i thought it'd
be interesting to cover it's so hard to
start where to begin because it's like a
list of stuff but
it's just ever since she's been pregnant
i've just literally
seen a different side to her and the
crazy thing is that
i've seen certain red flags like this
before she was even pregnant but i would
ignore them you know i'm saying it's
just my stubbornness sometimes
and it was cool for like the first six
months you know i'm saying when we first
met
but then she started turning left you
know i'm saying from little things like
she's just very manipulative she's uh
she hits
uh i cuz i don't want to say abusive
because i feel like when you call a girl
abusive like it's kind of like
weak because you know i'm a man okay
call it what it is if she hits you and
she can't use her words
it's you know when i mention this stuff
people like abby you're overblowing it
and the reason why it seems overblown is
because a lot of dudes would do what
this guy does where they tolerate
women being physically like this and
she's not just done this with him she's
done this with a bunch of dudes that
she's dated
enablers yep and so people who do this
stuff
very consistently do it yeah i've seen
it so many times i remember one time i
told a girl don't ever put your hands on
me again
just like none of my exes i've ever had
a problem i'm not them
i don't care but just knowing that she
did that to each tube
none of my exes had a problem with it do
you want to talk to your ex right now
yeah stop doing this [ __ ] don't put your
hands on people you know your ex
had a problem with it and now they're
your ex
they probably just didn't say [ __ ] about
it you know
keep your hands to yourselves hey man
please just listen i think we're all
grown people use your words man
man or woman there's no reason and
people who try to justify would be like
oh you do i'm not saying that men don't
put their hands i'm not saying none of
that
but i'm just saying from my experience
what i've had to deal with it's a lot of
ladies because that's the thing is that
whenever you say something like that
they think in their triggerness that we
[Music]
remove that there's another problem on
the other side yeah
when we say that women are objective it
doesn't remove the fact
that men are abusive we're not saying
that
women don't put their men don't put
their hands on women
no we just said that women are abused
and
it's not something that we talk about it
doesn't defeat the purpose that yeah
there's some trash ass man out there
but it's just like she does all that
type of
ish um she takes my phone for no reason
like she has control mind you like i
have never taken her phone i don't do
that because i don't want people doing
that to me
made us clash is her controlling factor
like i said she would literally tell me
who i can and can't follow now is she
doing the same thing
no you know what i'm saying she's
literally like following people she's
literally
you know i'm saying dated in the past
x's and all that stuff
and it got to a point where i had to
like check though i had to call her out
and then she pushed excuse like oh but
i've known these people since like high
school
what's his name flight reacts flight
reacts there miss a flight
you're an abusive relationship you are
in an abusive
relationship was was yeah he's not with
her
good but he's just talking about his
experiences i'm mad at it good but
that was effective a hundred and fifty
percent
that's that's gaslight god i'm glad
you're done with it another thing was
just mamie really turned off is just
like every time
we would chill together bro she's just
mad toxic bro
as soon as i see her the first five
things that comes out of her mouth
is literally let me see her phone or she
tries to reach for my phone like just
off of the jump bro
she i'm not gonna put her her business
what happened in her past
she had a really messed up pass and i
was just really trying to uplift her and
just like you know what i'm saying like
you know
get back to like her her her normal
jolly
you know self um when we had met she had
just some tragic things that happened in
the past when it came like exes and you
know traumatic things
so that's the main reason what honestly
kept me around cuz if you would know
what happened
you feel me you'll be like okay you feel
me you can't just turn your back on you
know someone like that but also at the
same time i never like try to lead her
on like i wanted her to be my driver
always told her like i'm not ready for
relationship
and she understood it it got cool we
were in the car and i picked her up
we're gonna go go to benihana
they got like hilly's you know what i'm
saying hills you go up and stuff
and mind you you know what i'm saying
when i'm going through that you know
what i'm saying like you mind you it's
two lanes you can't just have room to
just be messed around swerving
bro how would you feel you know i'm
saying if somebody literally grabbed
your phone
and she literally tried to drive me off
the road like she's literally a threat
to my life you feel me
but if anything happens to me everybody
i'm just saying
she pulls up to my crib multiple times
like trying to hit on me you know i'm
saying grab me by my neck and it's the
thing is
that she's trying to bait me to like
really you know i'm saying give her the
damn left and right
but you know i'm staying cool you know
what i'm saying
two days later bro she literally
apologizes like you see how i'm going
like it's just like she's using her
apologies and using
you know i'm saying this to play victim
and that's when she said that she was
pregnant
and this and that this girl has
literally lied to me about being
pregnant two
times bro she
so he deserves quite a lot of
accountability for staying with someone
or being around something
but you lied to me what's about
something crazy like that man i would
not have tolerated one third of
one tenth of what this man seems to be
tolerating
um and so at some point you you deserve
accountability for
for staying in that situation we agree
you're an enabler
yeah you're enabling her because you
know it's not because someone apologizes
that you
necessarily have to bring them back into
your life you can be like i forgive you
and move on with your ex
right so you enable that but what she's
doing man hey man but you know what
hey you know what he's out of that
situation so good for him uh apparently
he did get her pregnant eventually
though so
i hope you got some tests out of my
paternity tests and all that good stuff
damn that happened and that's the main
reason what made me done like when it
was december last
year i was ready to leave this girl in
you know i'm saying she drew me back
like a fish on some trapping
no no no no no you walk back in there
bro take some accountability
i'd say this to a lady i'll say to you
bro you deserve some accountability
no we said that to how many women who
said oh he's so manipulative
no no booboo you deserve some
accountability grown ass bears
yeah she played the tricks on you but at
the end of the day whose decision was it
hey man she might have brought the
tricks to the table but you ate the
cereal
oh turns out turns out
tricks aren't for your kid yeah they're
for adults too
and you've been gobbling them
it does true though real talk i ain't
mad at it nah doesn't put no tricks on
you boo
you you you have to sit down and eat the
cereal you brought that she might have
poured in the milk but you brought the
spoon
in the bowl i mean if there's milk
there's gotta be a bonnet
oh we never know i could drink it out of
you know just
man i did this motion right here and you
know someone's gonna be like guys pause
right here
there's always some idiot there's no way
the entire month of august bro bro
probably is the like
worst month ever i've ever experienced
with her bro
she literally uh does nothing but just
degrade me as a character
she says some just really really deep
hatred as
things bro i literally wake up you know
what i'm saying this morning
and everything like that but i'm taking
a [ __ ] bro this girl calls me
you know what i'm saying on facetime and
she literally shows off like her hickeys
you know what i'm saying she shows off
like some giant
texas [ __ ] size steak hickeys bro
you know what i'm saying like the only
thing i was missing was a1 sauce bro
i like your analogies
man you talk about a hickey that looks
this sounds delicious
can i have a hickey eggy medium rare
thank you
put the sauce on it put the a1 on it
how he talks this time she she did so
yeah we said what we said she did some
pretty
but you have to be uh you you're
enabling her to do some [ __ ] and you
walk back in here
she lied about her pregnancy twice
and you went back thrice and and now
that he's she's pregnant with his kid
man
she got a hold on him at least his
wallet for sure
that's the problem man 18 years and that
didn't end if i got the kid with
me you know and after the 18th birthday
he found out the kid wasn't his that's a
tough part man that's a tough part so i
was just like
ah man listen i hear i've heard so many
horror stories bro
horror stories horror stories bro i'm
sorry
um about just like dudes with baby mamas
or like we
you know as a side i think we talk about
dead be dads and the absentee father so
it's pretty regular yeah it's a common
thing
but
and from generation to generation has
been a trap we know it's part of
this culture the trap there is such
thing as a trap and there's not much we
could do about it
i've seen people use their kids as
hostages bargaining chips means to get
back at people
when you're a toxic person in your
relationship you're going to be toxic
when you're a toxic person and you have
a kid with the other person
and what's sad is it involves a child
it's just
and now the child is going to end up
being toxic and then that child
can end up with two children boom
they're toxic too it's like generation
and generation of toxic [ __ ]
you understand what i'm saying
it's like there's people that grow up
and it's just that
i've seen that it's just it's just
toxicity
she was not born like this she was not
like this and then the toxicity around
her
made the fact that made it that boom
and now she's at an age where no now
yeah i understand there's something that
happened to you in the past i understand
that she went through
but at some point as a human you are
responsible for the action that you take
after that it's understandable being
hurt and it's understandable being in
a situation that is really a mess but
after that
you are accountable for what you're
going to do with those trauma
i that was a phrase where it was someone
that was meeting someone else and
they were saying one of the phrases that
you should ask or sentence
or question that you should ask in a
date with someone that you try to hook
up with
is yo what are your traumas and what are
you trying to do to heal them and not
project them on
me what was there was a lot of
projection they give me your phone
that's a lack of trust there but
it's you that does that as a grown
person that almost kills someone or does
some
something erratic and the car swerves
and stuff like that
it comes from a real place but you're
the one doing that now and you're the
one responsible for that trauma but
whatever
we all have our little traumas me
included and we got to do something
about that
yep yep so listen my only advice to
young people in general
just be careful we all sleep with and be
careful who you
do it unprotected with especially
because man
black lives man i'm dealing with so
close to home
you know in my own family so it's just
oh word oh yeah we don't need to get
into it no we don't get that but i'm
just saying like
it's just it's not pleasant you see it
but i see it on all parts i see it
how it affects the kid i see how it
affects the father and the mother and
and i'm just like most of this is not
unnecessary get your egos out of the way
and prioritize the child
because in the end you're a parent and
you're being irresponsible i don't care
how much you feed the kid i don't care
how much you house it or clothed it
the environment that you're breeding
between the both of you
it talks it's irresponsible and you're
failing as a parent
so that's just my personal thoughts on
the matter
but maybe you guys feel differently uh
we'd love to hear your thoughts on this
matter and and all this but uh
that's pretty much all i have
accountability
what's that
[Music]